so you mentioned rewrite before or
refactor before features
if you were to refactor the Twitter code
base what would that look like and maybe
also comment on how difficult is it to
refactor the main thing I would do is
first of all identify the pieces and
then put tests in between the pieces
right so there's all these different
twitters of microservice architecture
um there's only different microservices
and the thing that I was working on
there look like you know
George didn't know any JavaScript he
asked how to fix search blah blah blah
blah blah look man like
the thing is like I just you know I'm
upset that the way that this whole thing
was portrayed because it wasn't like it
wasn't like taken by people like
honestly it wasn't like by it was taken
by people who started out with a bad
faith assumption yeah and yeah I mean
I'd look I can't like and you as a
programmer just being transparent out
there actually having like fun and like
this is what programming should be about
I love that Elon gave me this
opportunity yeah like really it does and
like you know he came in my the the day
I quit he came on my Twitter spaces
afterward and we had a conversation like
I just I respect that so much yeah and
it's also inspiring to just engineers
and programmers and just it's cool it
should be fun the people that were
hating on it is like oh man
it was fun it was fun it was stressful
but I felt like you know it was out like
a cool like point in history and like I
hope I was useful I probably kind of
wasn't but like maybe well you also were
one of the people that kind of made a
strong case to refactor yeah and that
that's a really
interesting thing to raise like maybe
that is the right you know
the timing of that is really interesting
if you look at just the development of
autopilot you know going
um from mobileye to just like more if
you look at the history of semiton was
driving in Tesla is is more and more
like you could say refactoring or or
starting from scratch redeveloping from
scratch it's refactoring all the way
down and like and the question is like
can you do that sooner
uh can you maintain product
profitability and like what's the what's
the right time to do it how do you do it
you know on any one day it's like you
don't want to pull off the Band-Aids
like it's a
like everything works it's just like
little fixed here and there but maybe
starting from scratch this is the main
philosophy of tiny grad you have never
refactored enough your code can get
smaller your code can get simpler your
ideas can be more elegant but would you
consider you know say you were like
running Twitter development teams
engineering teams
would you go as far as like different
programming language just go that far I
mean
the first thing that I would do is build
tests the first thing I would do is get
a CI to where people can trust to make
changes
so that if you can't touch any code I
would actually say no one touches any
code the first thing we do is we test
this code base and this is Classic this
is how you approach a legacy code base
this is like what any how to approach a
legacy code base book will tell you
so and then you hope that there's
modules that can live on for a while and
then you add new ones maybe in a
different language or before new ones we
replace old ones yeah yeah meaning like
replace old ones with something simpler
we look at this like this thing that's a
hundred thousand lines and we're like
well okay maybe this didn't even make
sense in 2010 but now we can replace
this with an open source thing right
yeah and you know we look at this here
here's another 50 000 lines well
actually you know we can replace this
with 300 lines ago and you know what I
trust that the go actually replaces this
thing because all the tests still pass
so Step One is testing yeah and then
step two is like the programming
language is an afterthought right you
know let a whole lot of people compete
be like Okay who wants to rewrite a
module whatever language you want to
write it in just the tests have to pass
and if you figure out how to make the
test pass but break the site that's we
got to go back to Step One Step One is
get tests that you trust in order to
make changes in the code base I wonder
how hard it is too because I'm with you
on on testing on everything I have from
tests to like asserts to Every Which
code is just covered in this because uh
it should be very easy to make rapid
changes
and no that's not gonna break everything
and that's the way to do it but I wonder
how difficult is it to
um integrate tests into a code base that
doesn't have many of them so I'll tell
you what my plan was at Twitter it's
actually similar to something we use at
comma so a comma we have this thing
called process replay and we have a
bunch of routes that'll be run through
so comma is a microservice architecture
too with microservices and the driving
like we have one for the cameras one for
the sensor one for the planner uh one
for the model
and we have an API which the
microservices has talked to each other
with we use this custom thing called
serial which uses zmq Twitter uses um
Thrift
and then it uses this thing called
finagle which is a Scala uh
uh RPC backend but this doesn't even
really matter the thrift and finagle
layer was a great place I thought to
write tests right to start building
something that looks like process replay
so Twitter had some stuff that looked
kind of like this but it wasn't offline
it was only online so you could ship
like a modified version of it and then
you could redirect some of the traffic
to your modified version and diff those
two but it was all online but there was
no like Ci in the traditional sense I
mean there was some but like it was not
full coverage so you can't run all of
Twitter offline to test something well
then this was another problem you can't
run all of Twitter
right period Twitter any one person
camera Twitter runs in three data
centers and that's it yeah there's no
other place you can run Twitter which is
like
George you don't understand this is
modern software development no this is
like why can't it run on my
laptop
yeah okay well I'm not saying you're
gonna download the whole database to
your laptop but I'm saying all the
middleware and the front end should run
on my laptop right
that sounds really compelling yeah
yeah but can that be achieved by a code
base that grows over the years I mean
the three data centers didn't have to be
right because if they're totally
different like designs the problem is
more like like why did the code base
have to grow what new functionality has
been added to compensate for the the
lines of code that are there
one of the ways to explain is that the
incentive for software developers to
move up in the companies to add code
to add and especially you know what the
incentive for politicians to move up on
the political structures to add laws
yeah same problem yeah
yeah if uh the flip side is to simplify
simplify simplify I mean you know what
this is something that I do differently
from from from Elon with with comma
about self-driving cars
you know I hear the new version is going
to come out and the new version is not
going to be better but at first and it's
going to require a ton of refactors I
say okay take as long as you need
like you convince me this architecture
is better okay we have to move to it
even if it's not going to make the
product better tomorrow the top priority
is making is getting the architecture
right so what do you think about sort of
a thing where the product is online
so how I guess would you do a refactor
if you ran engineering on Twitter would
you just do a refactor how long would it
take what would that mean for the
running of the of the actual service you
know and
I'm not the right person to run Twitter
I'm just not and that's the problem like
like I don't really know I don't really
know if that's you know a common thing
that I thought a lot while I was there
was whenever I thought something that
was different to what Elon thought
I'd have to run something in the back of
my head reminding myself
that Elon is the richest man in the
world
and in general his ideas are better than
mine now there's a few things I think I
do understand and know more about
but like in general
I'm not qualified to run Twitter no
let's just say qualified but like I
don't think I'd be that good at it I
don't think I'd be good at it I don't
think I'd really be good at running an
engineering organization at scale
I think I could lead a very good
refactor of Twitter and it would take
like six months to a year and the
results to show at the end of it would
be feature development in general takes
10x less time 10x less man hours
that's what I think I could actually do
um do I think that it's the right
decision for the business
above my pay grade
yeah but a lot of these kinds of
decisions are above everybody's pay
grade I don't want to be a manager I
don't want to do that I just like like
if you really forced me to yeah it would
make me maybe
make me upset
if I had to make those decisions
yeah but a refactor is so compelling if
this is to become something much bigger
than what Twitter was
is it feels like a refactor has to be
coming at some point George or Junior
software engineer every Junior software
engineer wants to come in and refactor
with all code
okay like that's like your opinion man
yeah it doesn't you know sometimes
they're right
well like whether they're right or not
it's definitely not for that reason
right it's definitely not a question of
engineering prowess it is a question of
maybe what the priorities are for the
company and I did get more intelligent
like feedback from people I think in
good faith like saying that
um from actually from Milo and like you
know from from Milan sort of like like
people were like well you know I stopped
the world refactor might be great for
engineering but you know we have a
business to run
and hey above my pay grade